han pasado seis días desde el asalto a
los edificios del gobierno en Brasilia y
Jair bolsonaro Ya está bajo presión el
expresidente brasileño es ahora blanco
de una investigación de la Corte Suprema
que busca determinar los instigadores de
los disturbios del 8 de enero en los que
miles de personas participaron las
sospechas aumentaron después de que
bolsonaro publicara un video en Facebook
en el que cuestionaba la limpieza de las
elecciones presidenciales que llevaron a
Luna al poder publicado dos días después
de los disturbios el video Fue borrado
rápidamente pero el jueves Alexander de
moraes accedió a la petición de los
fiscales de investigar más a fondo esta
noticia llega horas después de que se
descubriera un posible plan de
intervención electoral en forma de un
proyecto de decreto encontrado en el
domicilio de Anderson Torres el ex
ministro de justicia y jefe de seguridad
de bolsonaro es buscado por el tribunal
supremo por presunta convivencia con
quienes asaltaron la presidencia el
actual ministro de Justicia dice que el
decreto pretendía anular las elecciones
el documento es el eslabón de una serie
de acontecimientos que comienza el 30 de
octubre
día de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones y termina el ocho de enero
pero Torres afirmó en Twitter que el
documento había sido apartado para ser
triturado y fue sacado de contexto en mi
casa había una pila de documentos para
desechar donde muy probablemente se
encontraba el material descrito en el
artículo todo sería llevado a triturar
en su momento dicho documento fue
sustraído cuando yo no estaba allí
Mientras tanto la justicia sigue
deteniendo a los bolsonaristas
Implicados En los disturbios más de mil
personas han sido encarceladas